[Musique]
comment éveiller les enfants aux valeurs
de la République c'est la question que
s'est posé une parente d'élèves Solen de
laaroc marqué par l'assassinat du
professeur Samuel paatti alors en accord
avec l'administration et les enseignants
du collège Charles pegy du chénero
encour elle a organisé une série de
rencontres entrex les collégiens et des
personnalités représentatives de la
République la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du Sénat le maire
du chîné mais aussi le juge trividique
spécialiste du terrorisme pendant un an
nous avons suivi ces collégiens dans
leur découverte de la
[Musique]
République on va donc parler de de cette
opération collégia et valeurs
républicaines vous en êtes la mèire si
je peux dire Soline de laaroc on va en
parler avec vous il y a Monsieur le
Maire du chaé puisque c'est dans cette
ville que se passe cette opération et
puis nous sommes chez vous thbo Dadu
vous êtes le principal adjoint de ce
collège Charles pegy peut-être un mot
sur ce collège c'est le grand collège de
public alors c'est le grand collège du
chéner concours c'est le seul collège
public du chéner concours on accueille à
peu près 760 élèves ça dépend un peu en
fonction des années autour de voilà de
de 700 entre 8 700 800 élèves donc
collège c'est 6e à 3e he tout à fait 6e
à 3e et voilà de 11 ans à à 15 ans alors
Celen de laaroc on va revenir à la
jeunèse de de ce de ce projet de cette
opération collégiaen et valeurs
républicaine je crois que vous aviez un
un un enfant qui était collégien ici oui
oui deux garçons deux fils qui ont fait
suivi leurs études ici et qu' on garde
de très bons souvenirs et à l'époque de
la création de ce projet effectivement
j'avais un enfant en 4e ici et il y a un
événement évidemment qui euh qui vous a
marqué euh c'est l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti l'assassinat du professeur
d'histoire géographie Samuel paatti à
Conflant saint-onorine assassiné pour
avoir montré des caricatures de mahomé à
ses élèves et ça ça a déclencher parmi
les collégiens ici et partout en France
beaucoup d'interrogations sur notamment
la liberté d'expression la laïcité et ça
a donné lieu à des échanges nourris avec
des amis de mon fils notamment ensuite
il y a eu un cours très beau cours d'un
professeur d'histoiregéographie d'ici
monsieur Roussel que vous pouvait
apercevoir mais on va parler tout à
l'heure voilà et je l'ai contacté en
fait et il m'a dit qu'il serait partant
pour faire un projet effectivement et
j'ai contacté la direction du collège
qui a tout de suite validé le projet oui
euh Tib donne adieu qu oui quand quand
Solen de laaroc vous a proposé ce projet
la première réaction c'est quoi ça va
être difficile peut-être alors ça va
être difficile très projet très
ambitieux on était on sortait à peine de
la période de confinement on était
encore freiner pour le ce genre
d'initiative donc mais ça fait
maintenant presque 2 ans que qu'on est
sur ce projet et que en équipe et
notamment avec Madame lar
Latour voilà on cherche les partenaire
et on
cherche à mettre en place voilà Richard
adolpierre vous êtes le maire du chîné
vous êtes aussi conseiller
départemental rendre plus familièr les
les valeurs de la République à des
collégiens qui sont parfois éloignés de
ces notions c'est évidemment fondamental
alors c'est essentiel c'est le c'est le
rôle d'ailleurs des des enseignants que
de transmettre ces valeurs mais
évidemment que les élus sont en première
ligne là-dessus et il me paraissait
naturel de donner une suite favorable en
tant qu'élu et et d'accompagner Solen
dans ses dans ses recherches pour des
des interven de ha niveau et je crois
que le voilà le le produit de sortie est
très réussi he on verra dans les dans
les jours qui viennent et et ça a été un
très très joli moment en tout cas ce
moment de l'interview j'en garde un un
très beau souvenir de voir le finalement
la maturité de nos jeunes sur ces
questions même s'ils sont encore loin de
la majorité légale si vous le voulez
bien on reparlera tout à l'heure avec
avec les les collégiats qui vous a
interrogé de votre propre interview
comme de celle des des autres
intervenants un mot avant d'accueillir
les deux enseignants qui ont joué un
rôle très très fort dans dans ce dans ce
projet
un mot Soline de la ro sur justement
Richard Depierre le dit Thib thba aussi
enfin Monsieur principal adjoint aussi
l'ambition de ce projet c'est vrai que
vous avez frappé
fort l'idée c'était l'incarnation des
valeurs républicaines pour que dans la
tête des ces jeunes il reste quelque
chose ça soit plus vivant pour eux et
plus des concept uniquement donc l'idée
était de frapper aux portes du président
du Sénat de la présidente de la
ministre de l'éducation nationale voilà
pour des échanges entre eux et ces
jeunes qui veulent en savoir plus sur
les valeurs républicaines et entre nous
avant d'avoir le premier ok le premier
oui c'est c'est parfois on est un peu
découragé c'est un peu difficile il faut
être persévérante voilà je pense c'est
le maître mot persévérance mais en
général l'accueil est bon ben je vous
propose on va accueillir deux
enseignants Édouard Roussel et Beranger
ber un qui est professeur d'histoire
l'autre qui est professeur de français
qui ont joué un rôle et
puis on va Monsieur le Maire on va vous
retrouver dans quelques instants avec
les avec les élèves pour parler de votre
propre
[Musique]
interview ré qui a bien voulu nous
accorder un entretien bonjour à vous
Monsieur Gérard larch il y a eu que très
peu de le moment où il y a eu qu'une
seule
[Musique]
chance et bravo hein boulot sol de la
rooc alors on est avec deux enseignants
qui ont joué un rôle très important dans
dans ce projet Édouard Rousel et
Béranger bélier Édouard vous êtes prof
d'histoire Béranger prof de lettrre
c'est ça il y a un cours qu'a fait
Édouard qui vous a marqué c'était un
cours qui a eu lieu juste après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty un cours qui
s'intitulait être libre et vivre
ensemble voilà et à la lecture de ce
cours on en a rediscuté avec mon fils et
je me suis dit c'est c'est Monsieur
Roussely qu'il faut dans le projet et
donc je l'ai contacté vous pouvez nous
parler un petit peu de de
ceours enfin pourquoi vous aviez fait ce
cours ou al tout à fait bah déjà j'ai
fait ce cours parce que il entre dans
les thématiques qu'on est censé aborder
en tant que prof d'histoire puisqu'on
est aussi amené en enseigner
l'enseignement moral et civique et c'est
vrai que c'est une thématique en fait
c'est une tension cette idée de liberté
et de vivre en société euh à laquelle
j'aime bien sensibiliser les élèves pour
essayer justement de leur faire
comprendre bah l'importance quand même
du du vivre ensemble tout en ayant cette
possibilité d'exercer cette liberté
cette valeur fondamentale qui est la
liberté euh pour concevoir sec cours
pourtant j'ai rien fait de
particulièrement innovant hein
c'est-à-dire que comme la plupart de mes
collègues euh ça a été un cours où
j'étis amené à introduire en discutant
avec les élèves en leur faisant soulever
justement quelques paradoxes je me
souviens j'avais fait discuter sur une
petite fable euh le loup et le loup et
le chien de mémoire donc ici pour pour
un petit peu justement évaluer bah quel
personnage vous trouvez le plus libre
des deux ou autres et donc on avait
échangé là-dessus et puis après
effectivement bah ça nous permet de oui
de de de de d'élargir la thématique de
poser eux des des questions et puis
alors il est il est vrai que ça s'est
trouvé dans le hasard du calendrier sans
doute après l'assassinat de Samuel
Patti il est pas forcément lié à cette à
cette tragique événement évidemment par
contre évidemment il avait il avait eu
il avait un écho et une importance à mes
yeux plus importante de ce fait un mot
alors chacun justement parler des des
valeurs républicaines vous avez à faire
des collégiens qui ont quel âge 12 ans
13 ans euh bah alors oui oui c'est ça
15 ans gr entre 11 et 15 ans est-ce que
d'une façon générale au fond vous direz
que les valeurs républicaine c'est
quelque chose qui leur est un peu
lointain pour pas dire étranger euh oui
tout à fait alors moi je suis professeur
donc de français donc ça n'a rien à voir
avec ma matière on s'est retrouvé suite
à l'assassinat de Samuel pti à devoir
malgré tout en parler quel que soit
notre matière et je me suis retrouvé
totalement dérouté euh dans alors par
rapport à au connaissance des enfants et
je m'en suis rendu compte que ça ne leur
parlait pas du tout c'est non pas qu'il
les connaissaiit pas mais que ça ne
faisait pas sens ça et que pour nous
c'était très compliqué à aborder à
enseigner quand on éétait pas professeur
de MC comme mon collègue et donc suite à
ça et bien est venu ce projet et c'est
aussi en partie pour ça que moi je me
suis impliquée dedans parce que bah
parce que je me suis dit tiens c'est
l'occasion d'aborder quelque chose qui
n'est pas lié à ma matière mais qui est
important en tant qu'enseignant je pense
à transmettre à nos élèves
vous avez le même sentiment alors oui
tout à fait puis moi je précise ça fait
plusieurs années justement que je
m'interroge sur comment enseigner ceci
parce que c'est un petit peu
théoriquement la casquette du professeur
d'enseignement moral et civique et c'est
vrai que j'ai eu toujours cette
effroyable constat de dire que bah il y
a une espèce de théorie qu'on peut
donner aux élèves mais qui ne fait pas
vivre en fait ses valeurs et donc
elle ne se transmettent pas vraiment
d'une manière entre guillemets classique
par un cours classique que il faut
vraiment qu'elle soit incarnée qu'elle
soit quasiment tangible en fait pour les
pour les enfants
et et c'est pas facile en fait dans des
conditions d'enseignement j'ai envie de
dire classique c'est-à-dire voilà on est
dans une classe on a 30 élèves devant
nous c'est c'est c'est pas des des
choses si simples à faire c'est vrai que
ça fait très longtemps que je
m'interroge sur comment le faire et
quand madame de laaroc est venue avec
son son très ambitieux projet je dois
avouer qu'au début moi j'ai eu très peur
parce queelle m'a tout de suite annoncé
des personnalités très haut placées à
interviewer mais c'est comme ça que je
l'ai abordé avec ma collègue après
derrière je me suis dit c'est une chance
inouie pour les enfants et c'est aussi
une chance inouie pour moi d'enfin
répondre à cette ou ce questionnement
sur comment je peux faire finalement
voilà de de parvenir à faire autrement
et quand vous dites justement que c'est
concret c'est vrai que le fait de
rencontrer des personnestiques que ça
soit la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale un ministre le président du
Sénat
évidemment tout ou un ma évidemment tout
de suite les choses sont plus concrètes
et et plus plus appréhensibles par par
les élèves alors tout à fait mais ça a
quand même nécessité alors voilà une
préparation un fond j'ai envie de dire
théorique parce qu'effectivement déjà
quand on dit valeur pour des enfants ils
ont pas forcément ne serait-ce que le
concept en tant que tel ils peuvent vous
réciter très facilement liberté égalité
fraternité mais moi mon but ça a
toujours été justement de d'élargir à
pas seulement ces trois mots un peu
dev al bien sûr déjà mais surtout
d'élargir à l'idée que l'égalité
finalement bah ça se ça se manifeste de
telle manière c'est aussi la fraternité
qu'est-ce que c'est parce que c'est un
peu le parent pauvre souvent de ces
trois valeurs voilà très souvent donc il
y a vraiment une volonté de pas voilà de
de m'éloigner un petit peu du côté
dogmatisme républicain si je puis dire
pour pour élargir et et de fait je je ne
sais plus quel était leut question non
de fait non non la concrétisation par le
oui voilà donc ça nécessité voilà c'est
ça quand même un tout un apport un peu
théorique surtout que on a été tout de
suite amené à finalement interviewer des
personnalités politiques et donc il
fallait pouvoir avoir un contenu de
question qu'il sache ce que ce qu'était
la fonction en tant que telle donc ne
serit-ce que ça qu'est-ce qu'un député
qu'est-ce qu'un sénateur qu'est-ce que
le président du Sénat donc ça a été ça a
été le côté un petit peu voilà a fall
tout de suite engranger mais les élèves
ont relevé le défi très facilement sol
de voilà oui merci Patrice vous
comprenez mieux le l'énorme travail de
fond qui a été réalisé par ces deux
professeur voilà parce que c'est ça que
je voulais souligner oui je voulais
revenir justement ENF vous en avez dit
un mot mais Ben Roger aussi euh oui
comment ça se prépare ces rencontres
alors ça se prépare dans l'urgence parce
que nous avons interviewé des gens qui
ont des emplois du temps de ministre et
donc la date nous a été fixée peu de
temps en avance temp avant et on avait
peu de temps pour préparer on avait fait
le choix aussi de choisir des élèves pas
une classe particulière mais des élèves
déjà investis dans la vie du collège
donc membre du CVC du Conseil de Vie et
citoyenne et du coup qui était on leur a
présenté le projet en leur disant que
s'investisser les volontaires on a été
agréablement surpris parce que ils ont
tous répondu à l'appel et voilà le
problème a été à chaque fois de
regrouper ses élèves en général une à de
semaines maximum avant l'interview comme
le disait Édouard en en préparant
d'abord ce qui est cette grande
institution ce ce rôle qu'est-ce qu'un
ministre qu'est-ce qu' une présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et et alors notre
rôle était vraiment de partir de leurs
questions et de laisser les questions
des enfants d'essayer au maximum de ne
pas les reformuler évidemment qu'ell
soit française ça c'est mon rôle
mais voilà mais mais qui est cette cette
candur de l'enfance absolument faut
pasécrire refaire les questions des
enfants c'est c'est leur question et on
a senti au fur et à mesure que les
parents aussi s'impliquaient dans le
projet parce que on avait parfois des
enfants qui nous disait papa maman m'ont
demandé de poser telle question donc les
parents venaient s'incruster un peu dans
le dans le
projet ouis c'est pas c'est pas facile
d'acquérir une sorte d'autonomie he pour
pardon bah c'est vrai qu'en plus comme
le disait Beranger ici le le projet il
est trans niveau c'est-à-dire qu'on n
pas choisi de le faire sur un niveau de
classe particulier et donc bah ils ont
pas tous le même bagage non plus de
référence culturelle sur ces questionslà
euh donc ça a été une difficulté
supplémentaire c'était de permettre à ce
que bah du de la 6e à la 3e leur
questions puisse émerger c'est a été
plutôt en fait bizarrement ça a été
assez facile parce que comme ils étaient
volontaires ils se sont vraiment tout de
suite spontanément intéressés au sujet
ils ont tout de suite trouvé des
questions certes on était obligé un
petit peu parfois de reformuler et puis
comme on avait un temps d'interview un
peu donné parfois on disait bah cette
question là elle est bien mais on pourra
pas vraiment la poser et comme aussi on
voulait cadrer sur la question des
valeurs parfois bon benah on éloignait
les questions un peu trop techniques sur
la fonction de la personne parce que des
fois il s'intéressaent vraiment à
comment ça marche un député et cetera et
pour vraiment revenir sur voilà quelle
est votre vision de des
choses et et alors c'était compliqué au
début et je trouve qu'après on avait un
rythme qu'on a réussi à trouver on avait
en plus un va de question on va pas se
mentir qui qu'on pouvait ressortir si
vraiment c'était urgent et qu'on avait
pas le temps de de préparer tant que ça
euh ça se professionnalise non mais on a
tout à fait découvert un peu les les
difficultés du métier un dernier mot
avant d'accueillir parce qu'on va parler
avec quelques-uns des élèves qui ont
participé à cette opération des des
souvenirs qui garde de chacune de ces
rencontres euh le le le retour que vous
pouvez en faire la aujourd'hui la la les
leçons que vous pouvez tirer de ces de
ces différentes rencontres en tant
qu'enseignant ou en
tantenseignantant citoyen alors en tant
que citoyen déjà moi j'ai compris que j'
une chance inouie de rencontrer des
personnalités qui de cette Akabi
finalement aussi facilement et donc
merci Solen parce que moi je tiens à
préciser une chose c'est que on a
peut-être assuré le côté question voilà
mais tout ce qui était prise de
rendez-vous organisation c'est madame de
laaroc et puis monsieur deadieu qui
permettait une facilité de calendrier
énorme et c'est vrai que c'est
transposable partout hein c'està-dire
que bah trouver une madame de laaroc et
un monsieur donadieux qui sont à ce
point-là investis dans le projet bah
merci à eux parce que ils ont vraiment
permis de le réaliser et et sinon en
tant que en tant qu'enseignant moi j'ai
c'est vrai que j'ai été agréablement
surpris aussi de l'accessibilité de ces
personnes en
fait pour lesqueles j'avais peut-être
mis un peu sur un piédestal voilà les
fonctions en tant que tel et en fait que
ce soit
ils ont joué le jeu et surtout avec
beaucoup de spontanéité c'est-à-dire que
eux aussi leurs réponse elles émergaient
on sentait que c'était pas préparé qui
avait pas d'agenda politique derrière et
ça c'est je les en remercie vraiment
parce que on a senti de l'honnêteté et
finalement ça permettait aux enfants et
à chaque fois le retour qu'on en a eu
avec eux c'était ça c'était ce côté ah
là là c'était super intéressant ils ont
bien ils ont bien répondu à cette
question et c'est vrai qu'ils ne se sont
jamais démontés alors que on posait
aussi parfois des questions peut-être un
petit peu piquante enfin j'ose à le
croire de temps en temps et euh et ils
ont toujours eu une honnêteté de réponse
qui fait que à mes yeux le le le les
valeurs transparaissaient justement dans
leur discours on sentait qu'il les
incarnaent et ça sera un souvenir qu'ils
vont garder je pense ah bah eux oui et
moi aussi oui oui tout à fait en tout
cas je sais pas si Madame Beller veut
compléter mais non non je tirais juste
pour ajouter que moi ça m'a surpris à
chaque fois la fraîcheur de nos élèves
et il n'avaiit pas du tout peur en fait
peu importe la personnalité qu'ils
avaient en face d'eux et donc ça ça a
été une vraie richesse et je pense que
ce naturel a beaucoup joué dans la
réussite du projet et dans une époque où
c'est compliqué de croire encore à la
politique on le voit bien par le taux
d'abstention croissant je pense que en
tout cas moi en tant que citoyenne ça
m'a redonné foi en la politique en
rencontrant ses personnalités et je
pense que c'est un message important à
faire passer à nos
élèves merci beaucoup euh on va
peut-être maintenant accueillir les
élèves puent revenir bah sur quelquesuns
des des entretiens ou sur les entretiens
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont fait que vous avez
préparé et que et que cela de ne laaroc
a
[Musique]
initié CIT verger le toute la partie
PARM deux c'était leotager du BO et ce
qui un
[Musique]
plus
alors Richard dopierre vous avez été
parmi les personnalités interviewé par
par ces collégiens euh vous aviez
préparé un petit peu jamais c'est il
faut être spontané dans ce genre
d'exercice et donc non non j'avais pas
eu droit aux questions par avance et ça
a été une longue interview ouais voilà
et plutôt touchante voilà ils étaient
bien renseignés ils avaient bien préparé
le voilà ils avaient des complices donc
non non j'ai j'ai essayé je crois que
c'était aussi le l'esprit je connaissais
le thème mais mais voilà de de réagir
spontanément me para voilà sincère on va
dire et vous avve été parfois surpris
par le par des questions oui des
questions assez intimes ou des questions
assez intimes sur sur mon enfance sur
voilà l'Algérie il y a eu des des jolis
moments mais voilà pas rien de
déstabilisant mais voilà pas pas des
questions traditionnel on va dire alors
qui veut nous dire comment comment vous
avez préparé l'entretien avec Monsieur
le Maire bonjour donc je m'appelle
Quentin et pour préparer les interviews
l'interview du maire on a notre
professeur d'histoire monsieur roussley
qui nous a préparé une biographie du
maire et puis ensuite on a tourné des
questions donc sur la vie du maire et et
ses fonction en tant que maire du fé
voilà est-ce que vous saviez les uns et
les autres ce que c'est un
maire bonjour je m'appelle Ambre alors
non on savait pas exactement les
fonctions mais dans la dans le les
détails sinon vaguement oui on savait
c'est c'est un peu le rôle de mère c'est
un peu
de diriger la ville et d'organiser tout
pour que ça se rende pas et qu'il y a
pas des des chute ou voilà des des
bruits
quiig la vou
voil je crois que vous avez regardé un
peu sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez vu
que le travail de représentation de M
dans les cérémonies officielles
notamment est très important ça vous a
marqué ça oui bah on peut voir que le
travail de M c'est important pour les
pour toutes les présentation il est
accompagné d'une personne qui va
d'ailleurs mettre ça sur les sites de la
ville et oui il est présent dans dans
plat d'événements comme les
brocantes des Journées Nature et j'en
passe et gen passe des journées de
cérémonies voilà Richard de Pierre
justement bah c'est vrai que les réseaux
sociaux ont aussi changé la façon de euh
d'accomplir son mandat non ça fait
partie évidemment des des réalités de de
la vie d'un d'un élu même si euh voilà
le le le monde réel existe mais il faut
il faut ne jamais oublier que quand on
fait quelque chose il y a immédiatement
une duplication à faire sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que les gens consomment de
l'information consomment voilà sur
divers médias et aujourd'hui on serait
presque coupable de ne pas assurer cette
présence alors c'est une présence
institutionnelle quand je suis élu quand
je suis en écharpe je représente la
ville et et pas moi en tant que personne
et donc il y a un travail de relecture
un travail de choix des images pour que
l'IM image de la ville ne soit pas
altéré par voilà par des choses qui
seraiit misent de manière inopportune
sur les réseaux sociaux donc on est
attentif et et en général la
communication institutionnelle sort avec
un peu de temps par rapport à des
informations non vérifiées voir des fake
news qui sortent parfois avant la
réalité voilà et ben justement on va
vous retrouver dans cet extrait on va
vous voir interviewer par les par les
collégiens et vous leur expliquer
justement bah l'importance dans le
travail d'ber de du travail de
représentation et de sa fonction et de
sa
ville alors il 'occupent une partie de
mes weekends et des jours fériers ça
c'est sûr que quand vous êtes élu il
faut pas vouloir partir en en vacances
le 8 mai faut pas vouloir partir en
vacances le 11 novembre il y a des
cérémonies importantes il y a une une
douzaine de cérémonies dans l'année donc
à la fois c'est beaucoup mais c'est pas
évidemment l'essentiel de mon agenda
mais symboliquement c'est important ce
ces cérémonies ce sont des temps de
souvenirs des temps de
commémoration bien souvent d'événements
assez dramatiques hein des guerre des
des moments on a perdu on a perdu des
gens euh le 30 avril il y a une
cérémonie pour pour commémorer les
victimes des déportations c'est pas un
moment très joyeux mais c'est un moment
important et et et c'est important pour
la la génération qui nous suit les
générations qui nous suivent les vutres
et donc on essaie de se servir des
réseaux sociaux pour augmenter le
rayonnement de ces cérémonies et pour
que demain quand il y aura plus de
survivants le 11 novembre il a plus de
survivant de la Grande Guerre bientôt il
y aura plus de survivant de la guerre de
39 45 bientôt il y aura plus de
survivant la guerre d'Algérie c'est vos
arrièr grands-parents c'est vos
grands-parents c'est vos parents parfois
qui ont été meurt tué blessé voilà et
donc ces cérémonies elles servent à
transmettre la mémoire au-delà de voilà
de la symbolique elles sont
essentiellement là pour vous inviter à
réfléchir en mais pourquoi on est en
congé le 11 novembre pourquoi on est en
congé i c'est pas juste un jour ferier
on regarde beaucoup comme ça et donc à
un moment prendre le temps de dire ok
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé est-ce que je
suis bien au courant de ce qui s'est
passé on rediscut ensuite avec vos profs
entre vous et puis se dire à un moment
il y aura plus qu'un survivant et donc
est-ce que on oublie tout ce qui s'est
passé ou est-ce que ce qui s'est passé
passé était suffisamment grave pour
qu'on fasse l'effort de pas oublier et
comment on arrive à intéresser des gens
de votre âge sur des sujets qui sont
passés parfois il y a plus d'un siècle
alors est-ce que vous vous souvenez de
de la première personnalité que vous
avez
interviewé ah alors oui c'était du coup
madame Piron c'était la députée de la
circonscription des ivelines ouais de
votre cconscription oui voilà c'est ça
et euh bah c'était notre première
interview on était assez angoissé parce
que on avait jamais rencontré de
personnes de députés comme ça et euh
est-ce que vous aviez ce que c'était un
député euh bah c'était des gens qui
votent des lois ouis vous saviez ça déjà
ou c'est vos profs qui vous ont euh non
ça on sa déjà après on a eu plusieurs
détails en plus avec nos professeurs
pendant les cours parce que nos
interviews nous ont aidés pour pour les
cours qu'on a fait en classe nous ont
apporté des informations par exemple
avec Monsieur Trividic aussi euh mais
oui voilà c'était assez donc vous saviez
quand même ce que c'est ce qui était un
député alors elle est venue ici Béatrice
Piron et je sais pas si vous souvenez
mais
elle a une elle explique avec beaucoup
d'émotion ce qui s'est passé la première
fois qu'elle a revêtu si je peux dire
l'écharpe tricolore qui est l'insigne
des députés évidemment c'était c'est la
première fois c'était en 2017 quand elle
était élue et elle avait beaucoup
d'émotions vous comprenez cette émotion
là euh bah oui partager parce que moi je
pense que oui parce que la première fois
déjà onempte les chares mais aussi il y
a aussi enfin il y a la première entrée
dans l'hémicycle de de l'Assemblée
nationale et ça c'est important c'est ça
doit être grandiose et ben écoutez on va
on va vous retrouver avec Béatrice Piron
qui évoque avec émotion justement ses
premiers pas à l'Assemblée nationale al
c'est quand
même quelque chose de très très
impressionnant alors parmi vous je pense
que vous allez aller bientôt visiter
l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est cette
visite est organisée et je reçois
souvent des classes de la
circonscription qui viennent visiter des
écoles élémentaires ou des collèges qui
viennent visiter l'Assemblée nationale
moi quand j'étais enfant ça se faisait
pas ou moins en plus de ça j'étais dans
une école qui était très éloignée de la
région parisienne et donc je n'avais
jamais visité l'Assemblée nationale ni
quand j'étais enfant ni après quand j'ai
travaillé donc c'était vraiment pour moi
la première fois que je mettais les les
pieds dans dans cette
institution puisque j'avais pas fait
d'études politiqu et je n'avais jamais
eu l'occasion d'y rentrer et c'est très
impressionnant alors le bâtiment est
magnifique il est immense on s'y perd
beaucoup au début et puis évidemment ce
rôle donc on vous donne pour la première
fois une écharpe tricolore donc je sais
pas si parmi vous il y en a qui sont
peut-être aussi élus dans un conseil
municipal des jeunes ça existe dans
certaines villes euh donc porter
l'écharpe tricol alors pour la première
fois c'est quand même très
impressionnant et donc j'étais avec un
ami qui m'accompagnait ce jour-là et
donc com on vous remet un un cartable
avec l'insigne du député là que je porte
aujourd'hui et une écharpe une écharpe
tricolore il m'a dit mais
essae ton écharpe porte-la et comme
j'étais au bilu de plein de journalistes
ils ont choisi de me prendre en photo et
et ce jour-là le premier jour où j'étais
à l'Assemblée nationale voilà alors on a
vu Béatrice Piron là avec émotion quand
elle découvre l'assemblée nationale mais
vous vous l'avez découverte aussi
l'Assemblée nationale et pas n'importe
où puisque vous avez rencontré la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale euh
oui je m'appelle Théo exactement on a vu
madame s'appelle Bron pivé du coup on
l'a beaucoup interrogé on a eu que 30
minutes c'est dommage mais on a pu lui
poser des questions intéressantes et
elle nous a répondu et à la fin on a pu
bah
regarder comment ça se passait à
l'Assemblée nationale et ce qui se
passait oui vous avez assisté à une
séance oui est-ce que mais mais est-ce
que ça vous a impressionné de rentrer à
l'Assemblée Quentin oui oui on était
très content de rentrer à l'Assemblée
voilà ça fait ça fait une petite émotion
quand même et aussi ce qui nous a frappé
c'est l'importance qu'a bah la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale au
sein même de de l'Assemblée nationale
sur la distribution de parole entre les
différents députés et notamment il y a
le brun pivé a fait très fort car c'est
la première femme à être présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale donc une belle
victoire pour la France bra
alors il y a il y a une chose qui vous a
frappé sur laquelle vous l'avez beaucoup
interrogé euh on voit qu'en classe he
parfois il y a des il y a du Chahu à
l'Assemblée il y en a drôlement hein oui
du coup bonjour je m'appelle Samia du
coup oui on a vu du coup on assistait à
une séance durant bah quand on était à
l'Assemblée nationale et on a pu voir du
coup l'opposition qu' avait entre
certains députés euh ce qui était assez
bah choquant parce que on se dit comme
ça nous on a les lois et après le fait
de voir comment sont votés comment
débattre comment débattre du coup les
députés ça a été très très intéressant
du coup est-ce que vous dites si si ces
gens-l qui sont élus qui sont députés
arrivent pas à rester sage pourquoi nous
qui sommes des élèves du collège on le
serait euh ben enfin en fait c'est un
peu des députés donc je pense queils
avaient il faut qu'ils débattent
ensemble et donc enfin c'est important
qu' qu' expriment ce qu'ils pensent même
fortement oui et donc c'est pour ça que
c'était peut-être un peu dynamique mais
je pense c'est un peu normal et ben
justement il Bron pivé dans la rencontre
que vous avez eu avec elle elle explique
que bah s'il y a des débats un peu
virulents un peu violent et ben c'est un
signe au fond de la de la vie
démocratique justement ça n'est pas
représentatif de ce qui se passe tous
les jours en séance il y a des moments
où effectivement il y a du Chahu mais la
plupart du temps les débats se passent
bien bien sont respectueux et se
déroulent dans le calme pour autant
qu'il y ait du Chahu c'est la suite
logique de du choix des Français les
Français ont choisi d'élire des
personnes pour les représenter qui
représentent tous les groupes politiques
même les plus extrêmes et donc il est
normal que lorsque ces groupes
politiques se retrouvent dans une même
enceinte pour débattre de sujets qui
sont ant il est normal qu'il y ait de la
controverse qu'il n'apprécie pas les
déclarations de l'autre que le ton monte
c'est ça la vie démocratique j'imagine
que vous dans vos organes dans vos
conseils dans vos classes parfois vous
n'êtes pas d'accord le ton monte et
cetera c'est normal maintenant ce qui
est important c'est que ce soit fait
quand même dans le respect qu'on
ninsulte pas les gens on ne s'injurie
pas on en vient pas au main enfin il
faut qu'il y ait des règles et à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a un
règlement et moi je suis chargée avec
mes vice-présidents de le faire
respecter on vient de voir votre
entretien avec Hel brun bivé qui est la
première femme comme disait Quentin
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
puis vous avez rencontré aussi quelqu'un
qui est très important c'est le deuxième
personnage du du de de la République
c'est le président du Sénat
gérardché d'abord est-ce que vous saviez
quelle était la différence en gros entre
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale entre
les sénateurs et les député euh non
enfin globalement on pensait que bah
sénateur et députés c'était un peu près
la même chose et c'était juste deux
chambres qui se partageaient les lois et
qui les votai ensemble avec enent temp
et c'était pas si différent différent
c'est pas tout à fait différent
d'ailleurs raison le Sénat et
l'Assemblée vote vote les loi qu'est-ce
qui vous a marqué che chez le président
du
Sénat alors tout d'abord bah on a été on
a eu vraiment beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir l'avoir rencontré donc c'est pas
c'est pas donné à tous les élèves de
toute la France il est venu ici oui
exactement donc bah on l'a interviewé et
euh Quentin bah on est on était content
de qu' viennent pour qu'il nous
expriment ses ses valeurs de la
République notamment sur le gaulisme et
euh
oui je pense cétait une belle expérience
et euh je pense que certains d'entre
nous savaient global enfin avaient une
petite idée de la différence entre
députés et sénateur euh les députés ils
sont élus bah par des par des des
citoyens euh
dans une circonscription et les
sénateurs ils sont élus par des maires
voilà sont deè degré par desjà des gens
qui sont qui sont qui ont des fonctions
politiques qui
sont vous vous lu avez parlé de la
suppression du Sénat pas mis en colère
non mais il trouvait ça dommage et que
c'était important pour lui que le Sénat
existe et je pense aussi parce que c'est
d'après ce qu' nous d'après ce qu'il
nous a dit c'est beaucoup moins mitigé
au Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
donc peut-être que le Sénat est
important et peut trancher facilement
les les débats oui le travail pas est
pas le même tout à fait à l'Assemblée au
Sénat c'est peut-être moins
spectaculaire mais il y a peut-être plus
de travail de fond au Sénat en tout cas
bah Gérard Larché explique dans
l'entretien qu'il vous a
accordé combien le le Sénat est
important pour la préservation de nos
libertés collective et
individuelle je pense d'abord pour poser
la question pourquoi deux chambres on
l'a dit tout à l'heure pour stabiliser
pour se donner le temps de la lecture
pour
avoir une
représentation de parlementaires qui
sont issus de corps électoraux
différents quand vous allez avoir 18 ans
vous allez pouvoir voter pour les
députés mais vous pourrez pas voter pour
les sénateurs il faut attendre d'être
conseiller municipal du chaîner rencour
par exemple pour voter pour les
sénateurs donc un mode de scrutin
différent une représentations
différentes et donc une capacité à
éviter de tomber dans les excès
et je dois dire que ceux qui sont pour
le
monocamérisme c'est parce qu'en fait ils
ont le sentiment que c'est le Sénat
parfois complexifie les choses parce
qu'il est surtout très attentif aux
libertés individuelle et collective
alors après le président du Sénat une
autre personnalité très importante qui
est aujourd'hui président de chambre à
la cour d'appel de Versailles et qui
était un des grands magistrats euh du du
parquet antiterroriste juge
antiterroriste c'est Marc Trividic euh
vous vous souvenez de de cet entretien
euh oui c'était un peu plus poussé sur
la question de justice qu'on avait pas
forcément évoqué avec les autres
personnes qu'on avait interviewé c'était
plus politique là c'était vraiment la
justice parce qu'il était il a une
expérience dans le domaine
antiterrorisme et euh du coup c'était un
peu plus violent enfin il y avait des
choses un peu plus
poussées que les autres est-ce que vous
est-ce que ça vous interpelle le fait
que parfois voilà il y a des des jeunes
gens qui ont à votre âge peut-être un
peu plus âgé que vous qui sont qui se
peuvent s'enrôler dans des dans des
groupes terroristes ou qui peuvent être
attirés par le groupe terroriste est-ce
que c'est des choses dont vous parlez
entre vous non pas forcément parce que
nous on a pris à s'en préserver c'est
pas vraiment très très présent en France
euh par contre dans d'autres pays oui
c'est beaucoup plus présent et euh et
oui enfin moi par exemple de mon avis je
peux comprendre qu'il y a certains
avantages qui disent qui sur leur site
et que les gens voient mais il y a
certaines d'autres choses enfin qui qui
disent pas et c'est ça qui est dommage
en fait parce qu'ils s'enrôlent alors
qu'ils savent pas vraiment tout en
global comme ça est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut vous faire peur le le
quand on parle de terrorisme de
terroriste bah quand même la notion de
terrorisme est
assez bah on entend le mot déjà terreur
dans rien que dans le mot terrorisme et
bah oui c'est quelque chose bah qui est
déjà assez triste déjà et aussi assez
bah comment dire assez bah oui
angoissant enfin c'est quelque chose
quand on en parle on se sent pas
forcément à l'aise ou bien et pouvoir en
parler avec un juge du coup bah ça a été
céit important oui voilà et puis vous
rappelez que le le projet collégien et
valeur républicaine est né aussi bah de
de l'assassinat de de de ce professeur
qui était Samuel pati justement par par
un terroriste qutin tu voulais rajouter
quelque chose oui bah c'est vrai que
c'est quand même assez enfin c'est le le
terrorisme ça peut faire peur surtout
que ça c'est souvent des personnes qui
n'ont rien demandé qui peuvent ve être
victime de terrorisme et des fois ce qui
fait peur c'est notamment que bah ça
soit des gens qu'on pensé plutôt stable
mais qui en fait voilà qui se révèle
tout d'un coup pour faire des choses
terribles et justement bah le le juge
Marc tric faut dire le président Marc
trvidic vous explique comment internet
joue un rôle essentiel et parfois
terrible dans le recrutement des
terroristes aujourd'hui évidemment savez
bien que ces dernières années il y a
tellement eu l'explosion des d'abord
site Internet puis les réseaux sociaux
que bon il av tort de se priver moi
quand j'ai commencé d'antiterrorisme ça
n'existait pas en 2000 ça se passait pas
comme ça il y avait encore des journaux
interdits qui passaient de main à la
main des papiers du papier c'est
extraordinaire bon et après on a vu les
premiers sites Internet à partir de 2002
2003 à l'occasion de de la où là les les
les les groupes terroristes de l'époque
en tout cas qui était alqaïda en Irak
enfin le groupe alzarkaoui se sont dit
on va créer des brigades médiatiques
pour mettre sur les réseaux internet des
sites internet euh notre propagande avec
avec une idée très simple on va montrer
les images de de victimes musulmanes des
frappes américaines et puis après la
solution c'était des glorieux mjahidin
sur des purç Arabes bon c'est pas tout à
fait comme ça en Irak mais c'était les
images et comme ça il y avait voilà ce
qu'ils nous font et voilà la solution
vient nous rejoindre c'était assez
binaire et ont commencé à mettre ça donc
il y avait des brigades médiatiques ils
avaient pas des kalashnikov ils avaient
des caméras et ils filmaient et puis ils
ont créé une grosse centrale médiatique
qui s'appelait alchouou chumou àislam
qui qui qui qui prenait tout ça et qui
diffusait sur la planète entière ce ce
ça et du coup des jeunes qui se
trrouvaient à tour à roubet ou n'importe
quoi se retrouvaient sur leur écran avec
la propagande en direct pas besoin
d'aller dans une mosquée salafiste pas
besoin de se procurer la petite revue et
C et Cera pas besoin d'aller dans une
dans dans une cave pour discuter on
avait tout directement donc c'est c'est
rentré dans tous les foyers la force des
des des groupes terroristes modernes
c'est cette modernité ils ont beaucoup
de jeunes qui Manent très très bien
l'outil informatique qui man très très
bien les réseaux sociaux et donc il se
servent de cette modernité ça paraît
absurde parce qu'ils sont d'un idéologie
justement salafist on revient aux
ancêtres faut vivre comme à l'époque du
Prophète sauf que bah ils utilisent tous
les moyens techniques modernes euh de
premières technologie pour
endoctriner voilà et ils savent à quiils
ont
affaire le ils ne vont pas faire pareil
ils vont pas utiliser le même le même
discours s'il s'adressent à une
population en France ou s'il s'adressent
à une population au Pakistan ou en
Jordanie ça sera pas du tout le même
discours c'est très intéressant à voir
il s'adapte vraiment au pays cible B
ranger Bellier et Édouard Roussel on
vient d'évoquer avec vos élèves voilà
les quelques souvenirs des interviews
qu'ils ont en fait de ces personnalités
euh est-ce que vous vous euh vous servez
aussi de de de ces moments encore dans
dans vos rapports avec vos élèves ou
dans vos cours alors bah c'est c'est le
but en soi alors il est vrai que la
difficulté c'est que l'ensemble des
élèves qu'on a qui participent à ces
interviews on les a pas forcément avec
nous en classe donc il y a pas forcément
une réappropriation de ce qui s'est dit
immédiatement on avait fait en sorte
justement d'avoir l'interview de Marc
Trividic qui soit qu'il a un public de
deux classes de 4e parce que comme les
thématiques de la justice c'est c'était
des en lien avec le programme et ça
vraiment on a pu le réaborder enfin en
tout cas pour ma discipline ici j'ai pu
vraiment m'appuyer sur son discours pour
ensuite évoquer ces questions de justice
mais sinon l'idée en fait pour nous
intern au collège de ces de ces
interviews c'est qu'on les enregistre
avec notre studio de web radio donc
c'est ce qui ajoute en plus une
dimension supplémentaire à l'idée que
c'est pas un projet qu'on peut faire
partout parce qu'il faut aussi avoir ce
matériel et euh et ce le le l'idée c'est
de créer des petits podcasts alors au
début on avait pensé faire ça avec le
club web radio interne à l'établissement
mais bah c'est pareil il y a des
difficultés de calendrier les élèves
sont pas toujours présents le professeur
qui anime aussi donc finalement ça va se
faire plutôt bah de par par moi-même ici
de mon côté et l'idée c'est c'est de
créer des petites capsules audio écouter
un podcast en fait à destination ensuite
des enseignants de cet établissement des
élèves de cet établissement qui seront
publiés sur un sur le site internet de
l'établissement là aussi mais ça demande
tout un montage dont j'avoue je n'ai pas
encore pris vraiment le temps de le
faire mais j'attends impatiemment la la
fin donc là de la période où on sera
libéré des cours puisque avec le brevet
qui arrive et ça va me permettre de
d'avoir un peu plus de temps pour mener
ceci et j'espère qu'on pourra publier
soit vraiment avant les grandes vacances
soit à la rentrée prochaine pour que ce
soit accessible dès le début de l'année
prochaine Banger bélier elle un
sentiment sur euh bah ces interviews et
puis sur l'utilité qu'elles ont dans
votre enseignement alors moi c'est
essentiellement plutôt la relation qu'on
a noué avec les élèves on a travaillé
différemment on a travaillé à
l'extérieur des élèves qu'on a pas
forcément en classe je trouve que ça
nouer des contacts plus humains je
pense des échanges plus vrais avec des
élèves qu'on connaît moins qu'on
découvre donc ça c'est un vrai plus et
puis dans ma discipline c'est plus
compliqué à exploiter mais j'y
réfléchirai il y aura forcément un bon
usage à réinvestir dans les lettres bah
bravo pour votre application bravo à à
Solen de laaroc pour pour cette pour
cette
opération formidable et puis bravo à
tout voilà vous êtes en fait vous êtes
des journalistes quoi en gr les
journalistes en herb peut-être qu'il y
en a qui son CIS que ça ça a peut-être
créé un peu des carrières parce que je
sais que les éèves maintenant se battent
pour avoir les micros
merci à tous merci
[Musique]
bra